[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
guten abend und willkommen christian
otto ist auch dabei für den sport sehr
gern genannt und wir haben unter anderem
diese themen für sie
der letzte soldat die letzten flieger
die usa sind raus aus afghanistan die
taliban übernehmen den flughafen in
kabul
wie messen wir die pandemie die
bundesregierung will die korona
maßnahmen künftig an der zahl der
krankenhausfälle ausrichten
und erfolgreicher tag bei den
paralympics vor allem im radsport
sammelt das deutsche team jede menge
medaillen
wir beginnen in kabul mit einem
beschämenden moment für die usa unter
dem jubel der taliban zieht sich die
weltmacht nach 20 jahren aus afghanistan
zurück geschätzt
240.000 menschen starben in diesem
langen und teuren krieg auch fast 2500
us-soldaten
der einsatz war eine reaktion auf die
terroranschläge vom 11 september im
oktober 2001 beginnen die usa in
afghanistan ihren krieg gegen den terror
zusammen mit nato truppen besetzen und
kontrollieren sie das land die taliban
ziehen sich zurück doch schon ab 2006 r
starken sie wieder letztes jahr
schließen die usa ein abkommen mit den
taliban und verkünden ihren abzug in der
vergangenen nacht dann verlässt mit
major general chris dorner coo der
letzte us soldat afghanistan
die abreise berichtet
im feuerschein der eigenen raketenabwehr
verschwindet die letzte us
militärmaschine im himmel über kabul
kurz darauf beginnt ein freudenfeuerwerk
in den straßen feiern die für die
amerika eine besatzungsmacht war in
washington verkündet kurz darauf der
chef des zentralkommandos zerknirscht
das ende einer gescheiterten mission sie
wollten uns raus sagen und wir wollten
raus mit unseren leuten und mit unseren
freunden und partnern so hatten wir für
eine kurze zeit eine gleiche sicht der
dinge wir waren uns einig
sie arbeiteten für einige tage mit dem
feind zusammen dem sie am ende nichts
brauchbares hinterlassen wollten außer
millionen dollar der schrott wie
zerstörte flugzeuge und hubschrauber
am morgen inszenieren die taliban die
übernahme des flughafens als triumphzug
taliban sprecher mudschahid spricht beim
pressetermin auf dem rollfeld von einem
großen tag
ich gratuliere allen afghanen dieser
sieg ist eine lektion für die besatzer
für die ganze welt wir wollen gute
beziehungen zu den usa und allen staaten
dieser sieg gehört uns allen
[Musik]
bilder aus der provinz homs im
siegesrausch tragen taliban-anhänger
särge mit den flaggen der usa
großbritanniens frankreichs und der nato
symbolisch zu grabe
europäer und amerikaner wollen noch
hunderte landsleute und zehntausende
ortskräfte evakuieren mit hilfe der
neuen machthaber oder zumindest mit
deren duldung
wir werden die taliban ihr versprechen
erinnern menschen ungehindert ausreisen
zu lassen sie haben zugesichert dass
jeder der gültige papiere hat das land
in sichere und geordneter weise
verlassen
am tag eins nach dem abzug der usa
warten nun alle darauf zu sehen ob die
worte der taliban von kooperation und
versöhnung leere versprechen sind oder
nicht
fragen wir unseren korrespondenten in
washington immer tee wissen wie nehmen
die amerikaner diesen abzug war
also nicht wenige sind natürlich
erschüttert zum selbstbild der
supermacht gehört ja immer dazu dass man
eigentlich keine niederlage erleidet
jedenfalls keine so große aber in diesem
fall ist das eben so das ist eine grosse
niederlage für joe biden und für die usa
auch wenn sich manche wünschen dass eine
niederlage am liebsten irgendwie
aussehen sollte wie ein sieg oder
wenigstens wie ein unentschieden also
präsident biden wird jetzt sehr hart
arbeiten müssen um diese niederlage doch
etwas verträglicher erscheinen zu lassen
indem er zum beispiel alles dafür tut
dass amerikanische staatsbürger aber
auch afghanische ortskräfte doch noch
rauskommen aus dem land dass er druck
auf die taliban ausgeübt damit menschen
und frauenrechte eingehalten werden und
dass er dafür sorgt dass amerika eben
nicht wieder ziel eines terror-anschlags
wird der von afghanistan ausgeht wenn
ihm das gelingt dann glaube ich dann
wird ihm das ganze dieser abzug nicht
nur nicht schaden sondern vielleicht
sogar nützen weil er eben amerikas
längsten krieg beendet hat danke nach
washington hat er es
ja wie soll es nun weitergehen mit den
gegen minden die das land noch verlassen
wollen aber auch und vor allem im umgang
mit den radikalislamischen taliban
ein wirtschaftlicher kollaps
afghanistans müsse verhindert werden
bekam bundesaußenminister maß heute in
pakistan zu hören er sicherte hilfe in
der krise zu wie er es zuvor auch in
anderen ländern der region getan hatte
nach der türkei usbekistan tadschikistan
und pakistan reiste maas am abend nach
katar das als vermittler mit den taliban
agieren soll
andreas koers begleitet für uns die
reise und ist jetzt aus der hauptstadt
qatars aus doha zum geschaltet andreas
deutsche diplomaten sind schon im
gespräch mit den taliban was ist darüber
bekannt
ja es mag verrückt klingen aber wenn man
ein bisschen rein hört ins auswärtige
amt dann glaubt die delegation die hier
verhandelt in doha jetzt doch einen
halbwegs belastbaren draht gefunden zu
haben zu diesen taliban zum sogenannten
politischen arm in aller vorsicht
natürlich und mit stand heute abend
sollen die taliban ein paar ziemlich
detailreiche ziemlich konkret der
vereinbarungen eingehalten haben sie
sollen ja sagen zu bestimmten themen zb
dazu deutsche staatsbürger mit gültigen
papieren durchzulassen sie sollen nein
sagen zu bestimmten themen zum beispiel
dazu groß angelegte bus konvois in
richtung der grenzen afghanistans
durchzulassen aber das ist ja das was
die bundesregierung ändern will hier in
den verhandlungen die wichtigste frage
ist damit aber natürlich noch nicht
beantwortet ob sich der taliban an den
checkpoints dann auch hält an die
vereinbarungen von doha und da sollte
man und das weiß man natürlich in berlin
nicht zu optimistisch sein
die einschätzung von andreas cüppers
live aus doha vielen dank
bis zu einer halben million menschen so
schätzen die vereinten nationen könnten
bis jahresende aus afghanistan fliehen
jetzt streitet europa wie eine
flüchtlingsbewegung wie
2014/15 zu verhindern ist die
eu-innenminister so wurde auf einem
sondertreffen heute klar wollen sich
dafür einsetzen dass afghanische
flüchtlinge in den nachbarländern
unterkommen konkrete zusagen für die
aufnahme in europa sollen nicht gemacht
werden
elf tage dauerte die luftbrücke der
bundeswehr über 35 flüge starteten von
kabul aus in richtung freiheit
am ende wurden
5347 menschen evakuiert aber noch immer
warten zehntausende auf rettung
deutscher afghanischer ortskräfte und
schutzbedürftige die bundesregierung
sagt sie wolle sie auf keinen fall im
stich lassen diese hoffnung hat auch
eine ehemalige staatsanwälte in die
darum kämpft zu ihrer schwester nach
bayern reisen zu können sarah schon
berichtet es ist ein verzweifelter
hilferuf den meiler mutter hat in dachau
von ihrer schwester nil ufer aus einem
versteck in kabul erhalten hat wir haben
unser haus verlassen und verstecken uns
nun an verschiedenen orten jeden tag
woanders wir verstecken uns den kellern
bitte wir brauchen eure hilfe zum schutz
für die beiden nennen wir ihre richtigen
namen nicht denn meiner schwester
arbeitete bis zuletzt als staatsanwältin
für die abgesetzte afghanische regierung
für ihr engagement schwebt sie nun in
lebensgefahr
sie ist einfach in diese position hat
versucht natürlich für frauenrechte und
auch für ausbildung für mädchen und auch
für frauen die schwierigkeiten hatten
und probleme einfach so sorgen dabei
haben meiler und ihre unterstützer innen
es vor einer woche fast geschafft die
schwester steht mit ihrer familie auf
der liste für einen der letzten
evakuierungsflüge der italienischen
armee ich war auch organisiert wie sie
dann zum flughafen kommen sollte aber
dann war dieser dental plötzlich hatte
man also hat der kontakt abgebrochen das
letzte lebenszeichen ihrer schwester
erhält meiler am wochenende wie es ihr
jetzt gerade geht wo sie sich versteckt
hält meiler weiß es nicht mir geht es
gar nicht gut auch emotional bin ich
natürlich zu ende das ist ganz klar weil
ich versuche zu helfen so gut wie es
geht ihre große hoffnung ist nun dass es
ihrer schwester gelingt auf dem landweg
vor den taliban zu finden
schauen wir auf die pandemie und die
aktuellen corona zahlen für deutschland
das robert koch institut meldet
5750 neue infektionen innerhalb von 24
stunden das sind drei mehr als vor einer
woche 60 todesfälle kamen binnen eines
tages hinzu die sieben tage incident
singt erstmals seit wochen sie liegt nun
bei
74,8
bislang entschied allein die inzidenz
über die korona maßnahmen bei über 50
zum beispiel durften sich nur noch drei
haushalte und maximal zehn menschen
treffen das will die bundesregierung
ändern statt der zahl der neuinfektionen
soll künftig die auslastung der kliniken
den ausschlag geben was das bedeutet
zeigt sibylle bassler am beispiel bayern
dort gelten schon ab übermorgen neue
maßstäbe die vierte welle in den
kliniken ist die deutlich spürbar
erstmals seit mitte juni sind wieder
mehr als 1000 kubik patienten auf
intensivstationen für die vereinigung
von intensiv und notfallmedizin
das alarmiert auch die bayerische
landesregierung wie entwickelt sich die
lage in den krankenhäusern
diese frage rückt nun ins zentrum und
die krone lage zu bewerten die
sicherheitsschranke ist allein die
belegung der krankenhäuser wir nennen
das die krankenhaus ampel danach
etablieren wir zwei warnstufe gelb und
rot für bayern bedeutet dies konkret
wurden mehr als 1200 patienten wegen
kogit innerhalb der letzten sieben tage
im krankenhaus aufgenommen gilt
warnstufe geld bei mehr als 600 kubik
patienten auf den intensivstationen
herrscht alarmstufe rot wenn die anzahl
derer die ins krankenhaus müssen das
heißt die hospitalisierung incidents
hoch ist dann heißt es wir haben eine
hohe menge an infektionen das ist ein
sehr exakte parameter wenig tagesgenau
und auch regional aufgelöst bestimmen
kann aber die länder haben regional
unterschiedliche krankenhaus kapazitäten
deshalb können sie die hospitalisierung
rate jetzt selbst definieren jedes
bundesland führt eigenen regeln ein
kritiker sehen das als problem es kann
nicht sein dass jedes bundesland da eine
andere lösung macht denn es ist eine
politische entscheidung wie schwer
belastet die arbeitsplätze in den
krankenhäusern sein sollen politisch
auch deshalb es ist von bedeutung zu
wissen wann werden welche maßnahmen
tatsächlich eingeleitet
eindeutige antworten darauf stehen
sowohl von bayern als auch vom bund noch
aus
in die usa und zwar nach louisiana
dort haben die behörden immer noch
keinen überblick über die schäden die
der hurrikan ida verursacht hat der
grund viele gebiete sind abgeschnitten
weil das telefon und handynetz nicht
funktioniert wichtige versorgungsstation
sind unterbrochen hunderttausende
menschen werden wohl mehrere wochen ohne
strom sein die nationalgarde ist mit
5000 soldaten im einsatz bislang wurden
zwei todesopfer gemeldet
die lage am deutschen arbeitsmarkt hat
sich im august trotz pandemie und trotz
sommerferien weiter gebessert viele
branchen suchen nach monatelangen
beschränkungen wieder arbeitskräfte nach
angaben der bundesagentur für arbeit
waren im august zwei millionen
578.000 menschen ohne job das sind
12.000 weniger als im juli die
arbeitslosenquote liegt bei 5,6 prozent
im vergleich zum vorjahr waren
377.000 menschen weniger ohne arbeit
in der korona krise sind hunderttausende
von mini jobs verloren gegangen jetzt
erholt sich die wirtschaft und viele
arbeitgeber suchen wieder beschäftigte
die auf 450 euro basis arbeiten ein
grundsätzliches problem finden die
gewerkschaften arbeit ohne steuern und
abgaben setze falsche anreize
aber gerade in gebeutelten branchen wie
der gastronomie werden minijobber
dringend gebraucht und jan hofer
das café krümel in köln hier arbeiten
vor allem minijobber
juli nisch der betriebsleiter ist ob
diese 450 euro kräfte angewiesen als ein
kaffee während der korona krise
geschlossen war musste er sie jedoch
entlassen aber rein die aushilfen musste
man im erstmal und sagen jetzt geht es
leider nicht mehr wir können euch wenn
dann erst wieder nehmen beziehungsweise
die tür steht auf sobald er wieder
öffnen dürfen so ging es
hunderttausenden minijobbern in der
krise sie zahlen zwar keine steuern sind
aber auch nicht abgesichert erst jetzt
wo sich der arbeitsmarkt erholt werden
sie wieder gebraucht
insgesamt gibt es in deutschland derzeit
etwa sechs millionen angemeldete
minijobs das sind 500 1000 mehr als noch
im märz dieses jahres viele
arbeitsmarktexperten aber auch
gewerkschafterinnen die anja piel vom
dgb sehen diesen boom der minijobs
kritisch weil die krise deutlich gezeigt
hat mini jobs bieten keine sicherheit
nicht für denjenigen der daran arbeitet
nicht für denjenigen der den job
verliert wir sagen
sozialversicherungspflichtige arbeit ist
die bessere lösung für die studentinnen
im café krümel passen die minijobs wer
allerdings jahrelang nur davon lebt ohne
in die rentenkasse zu zahlen oder
abgesichert zu sein für den sind
minijobs problematisch
starkregen und gewitter im süden bayerns
wegen schweren unwetter hat der
landkreis er den gestern den
katastrophenfall ausgerufen
in der ortschaft kaufen mussten rund 250
menschen ihre häuser verlassen das
hochwasser überschwemmte straßen und
ließ zahlreiche keller voll laufen
einsatzkräfte aus der umgebung wurden
zusammengezogen inzwischen entspannt
sich die lage etwas
die bundeskanzlerin ist für ihren
beitrag zur verständigung zwischen
christen und juden mit der buber
rosenzweig medaille geehrt worden merkel
habe sich stets für das miteinander von
religionen und für israel eingesetzt so
der präsident des zentralrats der juden
joseph schuster merkel unterstrich die
bedeutung von gesprächsbereitschaft wer
zum dialog bereit sei könne dazu
beitragen vorurteile abzubauen und
jetzt zum sport und der medaillenflut in
tokio unglaublich aber wahr der siebte
wettkampftag der paralympics mit der
bisher erfolgreichsten bilanz für die
deutsche mannschaft insgesamt zehn
medaillen dank der überragenden
radsportlerinnen die in den zeitfahr
wettbewerben acht podestplätze
erkämpften
die überlegenheit des deutschen radsport
teams offenbart sich in edelmetall die
erste goldmedaille des tages gewinnt
annika zeyen die
36-jährige vor neun jahren noch mit gold
im rollstuhl-basketball heute
triumphierte als radfahrerin im handbike
gold nummer 2 holt die annahme juhnke
auf dem dreirad die 21 jährige in rio
noch mit bronze diesmal fährt sie als
schnellste ins ziel zum paralympischen
sieg bei den männern kann steffen warias
genannt warrior im kampf gegen die uhr
die zweitbeste zeit auf dem rad
einfahren silber für den gebürtigen
thüringer neben vier weiteren medaillen
aus bronze noch eine in silber für vico
merklein wegen eines motorradunfalls
sitzt er im rollstuhl und fährt seit 21
jahren hendrik die heutigen
siegerehrungen auf dem fuji speedway
stark geprägt von schwarz rot gold
und zwei weitere medaillen für das
deutsche paar athen gab es im
leichtathletikstadion silber und bronze
im 200 meter sprint und im kugelstoßen
sie ist hungrig nach gold doch
weltrekordhalterin irgendwann beim susan
gewinnt nach ihren drei silbermedaillen
von rio wie das silber die gebürtige
südafrikanerin mit sei gelähmt im
unterschenkel läuft die 200 meter in 26
58 sekunden drei zehntel langsamer als
die niederländerin marlene frank rensing
konnte die nächste gold chance hat wenn
susan am donnerstag sebastian dietz
feiert seine bronzemedaille
nach zwei schwierigen jahren mit
schmerzen im oberschenkel stößt der
36-jährige saison-bestleistung 14 meter
81 kann damit sein gold von rio 2016
aber nicht verteidigen
und noch ein sieg dann hätten auch die
deutschen rollstuhl basketballer in eine
medaille sicher die mannschaft um
kapitänin mareike müller setzte sich
eindrucksvoll auch gegen spanien durch
gewann mit 57 33 und zog bisher
ungeschlagen ins halbfinale ein dort
wurden am donnerstag den
niederländerinnen das sind die
weltmeisterinnen ein großartiger lauf
und ich habe noch was was fast schon
unglaublich ist doch was das
würde mich sonnig und warm und zwar die
nächsten tage die details vergleich
kostet herr lee im heute-journal und 10
vor 10 spricht marietta slomka mit
außenminister maas wir danken für ihr
interesse wünschen ihnen noch einen
schönen abend und sind morgen wieder da
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
schon genannte und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter die tiefs über mitteleuropa
verabschieden sich allmählich und vor
allem das hoch über den britischen
inseln dehnt sich aus lenkt richtung
osteuropa kühlere luft aber bei uns wird
sie sich allmählich erwärmen und das
spüren wir schon morgen temperaturen
klettern bei uns schon allmählich über
die 20 grad marke und sieht hier nach
osten hin ist es etwas kühler
in der nacht gibt es im süden regen der
lässt aber bald nach im westen
deutschlands bildet sich nebel entlang
der küsten vor allem dann stern klar bei
tiefsten temperaturen dort um 14 grad
sechs bis sieben grad im süden
deutschlands ja und morgen im
tagesverlauf viel sonnenschein vor allem
im norden und im süden in der mitte
immer wieder kompakte wolken das bei
höchsten temperaturen von 17 grad in den
westlichen mittelgebirgen und 24 grad im
südwesten die nächsten tage werden
wärmer und sonniger temperaturen 25 grad
am donnerstag und 26 am samstag ein
schöner abend